i think fraud isn't necessarily the uh
the the important conversation though
and i wonder if that's a distraction
well that's what that's what i'm being
berated with constantly if you're not
and it's and it's countenancing you know
it's it's the wrong conversation
but i do wonder if it's on purpose
keeping meaning
as democrats keep screaming there's no
fraud there's no fraud and chasing after
this fraud narrative like now the
washington post
trump is going after process so there's
there's there's
the potential of uh
challenging votes right now the aclu is
going to be filing a countersuit to stop
trump from disqualifying hundreds of
thousands of votes in pennsylvania
under what they're saying is a violation
of the bush v igor ruling or the 14th
amendment more specifically
that mail-in ballots create a parallel
and separate track
for voting which is a violation of the
14th amendment
they're arguing that they put up this
which seems
completely absurd to me i mean if that
was your if that was your view of the
constitutional
constitutionality of mail and balloting
why didn't you introduce such a suit
before the election because it's a law
fair because they want to win
well exactly so it's not logical it's
just
it's just it's just throwing the kitchen
sink at a problem when you're when
you're
all but it's certain to be defeated i
don't know if
that in other words the the the notion
that mail-in balloting versus in-person
validating creates this separate track
that it's a violation of the equal
protection clause
that could have been asserted without
any election results in
and they didn't do it why didn't they do
it because they so because if they had
one pennsylvania
then that rationale wouldn't have been
operated absolutely if they won
pennsylvania trump would be like we did
it we won with the best exactly but
ballots are fine but that doesn't change
the fact uh there were there was a
supreme court ruling earlier
and they said we can't rule on it until
it happens and so they said kick it back
segregate the votes
and then we'll have a ruling later so
now here comes the later ruling but but
the argument about mail-in voting
isn't just mail and votes are different
from in-person votes there's a bunch of
nuance here notably
they're arguing that in democrat
districts the
the election individuals i guess were
allowing
voters in these districts to cure their
ballots if they had
errors on them and they weren't allowing
that in other districts thus
trump's team is saying if you have one
district that says
you can check your ballot we bring it to
you we go to your house and say hey
you forgot to sign it sign it okay your
belt's valid now and then in republican
districts they didn't do that creating a
higher margin of failure
you've created a two track where you're
you're you're slanting things for
democrats that's another
balance ballots can be cured per
state law and it takes a
large volunteer effort as far as i
understand
to retrieve the person whose valid
ballot needs to be cured
it's not always it's not just done by
election officials
uh across the board meaning public
employees
so if republicans are not getting their
ballot secured i would think that's
probably a function
more of them just not them not having as
many voters that need to have their
balance cured right
well i don't know the exact specifics of
that but
like i said i mean even in georgia where
i just again just was
they have a ballot curing process that
was all enacted by a republican state
legislature
so i mean the point is i think if you're
just saying this is
democratic fraud georgia to me is not
for example or
whatever malfeasance no no no no no no
impropriety
however you want to call it i mean how
do you account for for
georgia i mean that's that's a big one
pennsylvania obviously is where the
election at least was called by the
media
over the weekend but again georgia to me
stands out as something that
the republicans and and the trump
supporters who are going with this
narrative have
not even attempted to reckon with and
you even have the two
republican senators calling for the
resignation of the republican secretary
of state
just because they didn't like how the
election was being run they didn't even
offer any specifics that's why i
keep going back they're just throwing
the kitchen sink at a product for sure
i'm not eating sticks i'm not arguing
that the way they're going at it
is like this very slow methodical
logic based you know solution i prefer
when stuff is logic based i don't know
about you
no no i agree what i'm saying is they're
not going okay let's take a look at uh
washington state and go through the list
now let's take a look at wyoming and go
through the list what they're saying is
here the states we gotta win
fire the lawyers like i mean like fire
the missiles not yeah get rid of the
lawyers
so obviously they're going after
pennsylvania why trump
needs pennsylvania for any kind of
victory so of course he's going to go
after that through every legal mean
possible
and then they'll they're also filing
lawsuits in nevada i think
they've got a ton of lawsuits going on
across the board in a bunch of different
states but i think
there may be some uh
i think some of the arguments make sense
notably one of the biggest problems we
have right now and i have no idea what
the solution is
there was a court order in pennsylvania
that in philadelphia and allegheny
county
they must allow observers within a
certain distance to observe
and they defied the court order so they
counted
according to trump's campaign about 450
000 ballots
in violation of a court order now
giuliani has taken the extreme approach
saying
they're all spoiled because the secrecy
envelopes were destroyed already
therefore we don't know where these
bouts came from we have no addresses we
don't know who they are we don't know if
they were signed
and they didn't allow observers in
violation of court order disqualify them
this is why the aclu jumped in saying we
have to sue back to stop trump from from
winning this fight
if they if they disqualify 450 000 votes
it'll include trump votes but i think
that'll definitely flip it for trump
you could just as easily call that
disenfranchisement though i mean the
voters who cast those ballots had
nothing to do with
what distance observers were required to
stand at so true why should their vote
be negated
because we need election security
because we don't know who those votes
are for where they're from who signed
them the secrecy ballots were destroyed
so we could uh we could do a re-election
you know no
right exactly so this creates a very
serious problem
we can't create a system where we say
straight up you can violate a court
order and count
hundreds of thousands of ballots in
violation of a court ruling
i think i think there's some dispute
over whether that order was violated and
precisely the way
well so so but like i mean okay so a
difference of three feet
in terms of no no no no it wasn't dozens
of feet it was like
i i i read that it was a a lesser
distance in at least
certain well there's videos of people
examples like
50 feet away with binoculars right and
so you've got
according to giuliani 50 to 70 witnesses
i'm not saying you gotta trust the guy
i'm just saying this is their argument
they've got 50 to 70 people who have
signed on
to swear under oath they were they were
pushed out in violation of the court
order allowing them to be within six
feet
what do we do with these ballots well i
mean again my understanding is that
at least some of the time in
philadelphia which is now in dispute
the people who came in through the
public entrance to observe
didn't register properly and there were
in fact bipartisan observers
on hand maybe not 100 percent of the
time i don't know
well so it's a messy process this is
this is this is what we're getting from
the media
mainstream news outlets are saying there
were democrat and republican observers
on site
republicans never disputed they weren't
on site they're saying republicans
weren't allowed within the court ordered
distance
okay meaningful access is what they
argued so of course the media is pushing
its narrative the trump campaign
and you know trump's supporting media is
pushing its narrative but i gotta admit
i mean how do you deal with the
situation
in in in that regard like do we just
say this time it's okay we don't
you know we've got a legal dispute over
these ballots and i'll tell you this man
i'm
at first i was like look i tweeted this
morning trump is not going to prison
you know these people on the left who
are like trump's going to jail it's not
going to happen
and trump's not going to overturn this
election with lawsuits
but then things started getting weird
you've got these states are republican
legislators
are they just going to roll over and be
like we're going to certify the electors
for for joe biden in while this dispute
is going on or are they going to be like
no we're not doing it in which case
nobody gets 270.
well if they do that then they'll have
done something which is a hundred
percent unprecedented in all of american
history and whether they want to do that
i think is you know a little bit
doubtful
on the other hand there was an effort by
frantic liberals
in 2016 to lobby electors
to do something which at that point
would have also been with our president
in u.s history which is that on the
basis of russian interference
they were saying that they should not
seat electors for trump in states like
pennsylvania it wasn't just a marginal
fringe movement i was
in harrisburg pennsylvania i mentioned
this today on twitter
which is the state capitol when the
electoral college met
which is usually just a formality that
nobody even knows is happening but i
went on
in december of 2016 to watch it happen
and you had a mass
it wasn't it was a protest that had been
organized at the state house to badger
electors to not
cast their votes in accordance with what
the popular vote outcome in the state of
pennsylvania was
it would have been just a mind-blowing
uh
departure from everything that's
happened ever before in u.s history
and they were they were in the chamber
the legislative chamber they were
screaming and at the moment that the
votes were certified the electoral votes
were certified
the woman right in front of me in this
balcony screamed loud enough so that
everybody
could undoubtedly hear it she screamed
you just gave us hitler
so i mean when i see democrats and
liberals sort of scorning
republicans and trump supporters now for
maybe having some histrionic
interpretations of what this fraud
matter consists of a little bit yeah i
think i mean did you just sleep through
the past
four and a half years if anything you
made inevitable though inevitable that
there was going to be this backlash
yeah where however specious
the claims are in terms of voter fraud
or whatever else about the doubting the
legitimacy the legitimacy of the
election you'd have you should have had
no
doubt whatsoever that those were gonna
flood into
the public consciousness if for no
reason other than
as retribution for what was done last
time
hillary clinton did technically concede
the day after the election and trump
hasn't yet
so it's not 100 analogous but
i mean there were plenty of extremely
influential liberals lawrence lessig
robert reich
go down the list jennifer palmieri who
was on the clinton campaign i
i collected this at the time so i have
the quote receipts
um who were advocating for
the delegitimization of the electoral
college and you know
people don't forget about that and that
i think is
a really under emphasized
component of all this it's just as it's
almost like a vengeance type thing for
2016. thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you